رات العسكريه متسارعه خاصه مع اعلان
القسام استهداف مزيد من الجنود
الاسرائيليين وايضا الاليات في داخل شمال
غزه تحديدا معنا اللواء فيس دويري الخبير
العسكري والسرج لنحلل هذه المعلومات
والمعطيات اللواء دويري ولكن اولا سلام
تطلعين على مناطق الاشتباك اليوم سواء كان
في الشمال او حتى في الجنب تطورات متسارعه
اليوم جلال ليس فقط على صعيد الاشتباكات
بل ايضا على صعيد الخسائر التي مني بها
الجيش اسرائيلي بدايه قطاع غزه من شماله
الى جنوبه يتعرض لقصف عنيف بالطائرات
والمدفعيه واليوم ايضا شاركت شاركت طائرات
ال الهليكوبتر في هذه الضربات خاصه في
شمال القطاع ومن شمال القطاع سنبدا
اسرائيل اليوم قالت ان هناك نقطتين
اساسيتين تشهدان اشتباكات واسعه جدا
النقطه الاولى هي تقريبا في الشمال منطقه
بيت لاهيا جباليا و الشجاعيه وايضا في
الجنوب رفح في الشمال مخي مدينه جباليا
شهدت اشتباكات واسعه بين الجيش الاسرائيلي
وبين كتائب عز الدين القسام اليوم القسام
اعلنوا انهم في الثلاثه ايام الماضيه
دمروا بشكل كامل او جزئي 79 اليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه وايضا ال اعلنته قبل قليل
القسام حدث هام في منطقه الشيخ رضوان في
الشيخ رضوان اليوم القسام قالت انها
استهدفت قوه اسرائيليه في نفق وقامت
بتفجير النفق في القوه الاسرائيليه هنا في
الشيخ رضوان واوقعت خسائر كبيره جدا في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي بالانتقال الى جنوب
القطاع مدينه خانيونس كما ذكرنا هي واحده
او ثانيه ثاني مكان يشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
في اطار ما قالت اسرائيل انه توسيع
للعمليه العسكريه البريه لها من دون ان
تعطي مزيد من التفاصيل القسام قالت انها
استهدفت بالعبوات اكثر من تجمع للجيش
الاسرائيلي لقوات راجله من الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا في خان يونس هناك
اشتباكات بين الطرفين في اكثر من محور
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحاول مهاجمه خان يونس
من اكثر من منطقه ولكن حتى الان كما وصف
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه ما زال يقاتل
اعتى جنود كتائب عز الدين القسام بحسب ما
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي جلال طبعا هذه ابرز
التطورات العسكريه الميدانيه من دون تناول
الوضع الانساني او اوضاع النازحين وهو
متفاقم وكارثه بطبيعه الحال ذكرتي جباليا
في الشمال لواء دويري لفتنا اليوم صور
عرضت لقصف اسرائيلي في جباليا سنتابعها
بعد قليل وهو دخان كثيف ينتشر جراء هذا
القصف الاسرائيلي كما سنتابع بعد قليل في
في هذا الفيديو الذي سيعرض ما هذا لواء
دويري تقريبا اول مره نشاهده منذ بدء
الحرب نعم وكن لا هذه تستخدم في الحروب
خاصه الجيش الامريكي يستخدمها بصوره موسعه
وانا دخلت دوره الام بي سي وكان هذا جزء
من المعطيات التمارين حتى وهذا اللي هو
الدخان الابيض ي يستخدم
كحاجز لمنع الرؤيا
وا من اجل الاجراء والقيام بمناورات
يستطيع من خلالها هو يملك
المعدات الاسرائيليه تملك الامكانات
التقنيه لتتحرك في هذا ال ا هو
يغان اذا هو يعمل عمليه اعماء للقوات
المدافعه حتى تفاجا بظهور القوات المهاجمه
لحظه خروجها من الدخان في الحاله هذه تكون
قد وصلت الى نقطه الصفر و من اجل مفاجاه
المدافع فهذه اللي هي استخدام الدخان
كسوات خانيه لحجب الرؤيه في هذه الاثناء
يستمر الجيش الاسرائيلي بنجر بنشر صور
وفيديوهات يقول بانها لعمليته في داخل
قطاع غزه اعداد كبيره من الجنود جنود
الاحتلال اللواء الدويري كيف تقرا هذه
المشاهد في يعني هذا امر عادي هو يصور في
المنطقه التي يشاء قد تكون مناطق بعيده
امنه نوعا ما ولكن يعني كنا نرغب ان نشاهد
فيلم يبين لحظات الاشتباك والقتال وليس
حركه جنود في
منطقه ما وبالتالي يعني القسام وغيرها من
الفصائل لا يستطيعوا ان يواجهوا كل جندي
يتحرك او كل اليه تتحرك لانه القدرات
متباينه جدا وبالتالي اي اداره المعركه
الدفاعيه للقسام مختلفه في كثير من
الحالات تسمح لهؤلاء الجنود ان يتقدموا
الى نقطه ما وتكون نقطه
مميته قد يكون فيها كمين او ما شابه ذل
سمحني ولكن الوقت ضيق وكما ذكرت قبل قليل
سلام كتاب القسام اعلنت عن استهداف مجموعه
من الجنود على مدخل نفق وهذه ليست المره
الاولى كيف تقرا تكرار هذه التفجيرات هذ
الان يعني سواء كان تفجير تفخيخ لفتحه
النفق او في بعض الحالات داخل النفق حتى
يعني قراءتي لخطه القسام الدفاعيه عندما
تكون المعطيات لديهم ان الجنود من حيث
العدد والكثافه الناريه والقدره القتاليه
قد لا تكون القوات المواجهه لهم قادره على
ايقافهم الى ماذا يلجا يعود الى يعود الى
النفق يفخخ النفق يدخل خلفه يتم تفجيره
والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن بطبيعه الحال كل
يوم عن خسائر بالضباط والجنود لدينا
صورتين لطائره اف 15 الامريكيه هذه الصوره
الاحدث وهي اليوم ولكن ربما ليست واضحه
ولكن واضح وانت خبير عسكري قذيفه جي بي يو
وهي قذيفه ثقي
الاعما لدينا صوره ايضا سابقه في بدايه
الحرب ايضا صوره اوضح ايضا اف 15
الامريكيه تحمل هذه القذف يعني قذيفه الجي
بي يو انواع اذا كانت هذ القذيفه اللي هي
جي بي يو 28 هذه وزنها 5000 باوند موجهه
بالليزر درجه تستخدم ضد التحصينات ودرجه
الخطا 5 متر وبالتالي هذه تعتبر المنطقه
اللي بتسقط عليها تدم يعني اذا سقطت على
برج لا يعني لا تسقط البرج حتى تخترق الى
الاعماق وتصل وتعمل حفره في الارض حتى لو
كان برجا وشهدنا هذا في جباليا شهدنا في
جباليا في اكثر اكثر من مره للمره الرابعه
اللواء دويري ارو الاسرائيلي يعترض صارروخ
بالستي اطلق من اليمن ونحن نعلم بان ارو
يستطيع ان يصل الى خارج خارج غلاف الكره
الارضيه صحيح يعني خارج خارج غلاف الكره
الارضيه وهذا هو الارو مخصص الدفاعات
العاليه هو وصواريخ الثات وبالتالي يعتبر
على فكره هو تقنيا هو صناعه مشتركه
امريكيه شركه رافائيل ولكن هو مدعوم من
رايثون وغيرها في امريكا ويعتبر من
الاسلحه المتطوره ولا ولكن هو لا يعتمد
الاصطدام المباشر هو
يعتمد الحركه عندما
يصبح موازيا موازيا للهدف ينفجر فيتم
تدمير
الهدف يطلق من اليمن شكرا لك اللواء
الدويري لدينا معطيات اخرى سنعالج في خلال
الاطلاله الثانيه في تغطينا المستمره في
نشره الساعه العاشره الان نعود لمتابعه
هذه التغطيه معك ازدهار تصحي